[Aplausos]
vocês jogaram na escola é brincar ao ar
livre e de mexer na terra acreditam em
sonhos e na rua na possibilidade de
realizar acreditam que é possível sonhar
juntos criarmos uma nova realidade
olá eu sou maria aos eu acredito que sim
acredito que podemos sonhar juntos eu
venho aqui falar dessa possibilidade
como é que construímos não só em
conjunto um projeto comunitário e
educacional e sustentável para uma
sociedade mais sustentável
eu tenho de mim eu sou professora eu sou
a mais nova a 5 não somos nem tenho as
costas quentes durante a minha fase que
vai fazer um livro
tive uma infância muito na natureza
os pais sempre viveram na terra
sempre vivemos agricultura e que nunca
tiveram a oportunidade de ir à escola
portanto eles consideravam que os seus
filhos
a melhor oportunidade porém entendo a
vida realmente ter acesso ao ensino
superior e ter a oportunidade de seguir
o seu caminho na loja da terra
a realidade é que a terra marcou muito e
eu vi uma infância e uma juventude
conectada com a natureza e sempre senti
essa necessidade do respeito pelos seus
todos os trechos animais suas plantas a
e também as próprias pessoas e sempre
teve uma ação muito ativa na comunidade
sempre pratiquei o voluntariado e ações
sociais
esse empenho que os meus pais tinham
prover filhos vai na vida e ea
possibilidade que amanhã que eu tive foi
que eles fizeram
elcio ensino superior de educação visual
e tecnológica por gostar empresários e
foi em 1999
portanto tenho
32 anos de escola porque eu comecei a
sair com uma maioria e nessa neste
concurso eu mudei de posição dentro do
espaço físico da escola e da sala de
aula já pensou estar sentado a ouvir o
professor e dar aula por estar na
posição em que estou agora que é com
professora dar aulas e essa posição
dentro do espaço da escola deu uma nova
perspectiva sobre educação sobre o
ensino é o tchan
descobrir um peixinho por desenvolver
projectos artísticos com crianças e
jovens
a tecnologia que a metodologia de
trabalho do projeto que no fundo é uma
uma aplicação do método científico entre
as crianças e os jovens podem
desenvolver projetos a partir de uma
necessidade de um de um problema que
existe na realidade e desenvolver seu
próprio percurso fazendo investigação o
propondo projetos e concretizando e
avaliando um fundo de garantia da
autonomia e que era uma das inovações
que houve
enquanto professora na educação ano
também houve situações na educação por
mais desagradáveis que eu senti
também percebi que o suporte teórico não
conhecia muito bem com a prática
educativa e eu sempre a mesma
necessidade de rever a minha atuação
como professora de procurar novas
pedagogias de perceber que ele estava no
bar da educação que caminha que podia
seguir para também permitir uma nova
educação para emoldurar a novas
aprendizagens meus alunos e este
percurso é reconduzir uma descoberta
a descoberta também que as crianças e os
adultos da mesma natureza e que dentro
de um sistema autoritário escolar nem
que não para fugir
realmente é a integração das crianças
mesmo processo de aprendizagem
não é não conseguimos atingir o estado
da democracia quando
as crianças não se envolvem nas suas
rotinas diárias não tem uma palavra a
dizer sobre as suas aprendizagens são às
centenas
nós sentadas a ouvir informação por mais
interessante e mais maravilhosa que seja
a explicação do professor
eu não considero que seja havia anormal
do acre conhecimento em todas estas
situações como ser mais curta de um
projeto inovador escola da ponte e
tamanho do seu mentor josé pacheco
escola é um projeto inovador que a
escola que não imaginava que existisse
não é uma escola que o que fazer parte
de meus sonhos
quando os meus filhos eu sou mãe de três
filhos da da flor que tem três anos da
violenta que tem 74 e realmente essa se
vê essa fase da minha vida em que pára
em colocá los na escola é bastante sobre
a escola para as crianças
a minha experiência é e como já conhecia
o projeto da escola da ponta e eu como
tenho pra escoar o 9º ano e que
conseguirem uma proteção mais integral
com base no respeito na unidas que essas
onde a equipa educativa trabalha com a
comunidade e com as próprias crianças é
uma escola com um projeto inovador
mundialmente conhecido durante três anos
nós vivemos um sonho projeto
as coisas mudaram a certa altura
precisamente em março de 2015
é portanto esse pedagogo que eu tanto
admiro e que foi o motivador dessa
escola am
veio cá guimarães em uma conversa como
eu
nós o conjunto de pessoas que foram ver
se encontramos a oportunidade de debater
o estado de atenção e fomos muito
entusiasmados 100 mil entusiasmados
porque eu realmente disse que vai para o
chão da escola comigo a repensar a
educação
eventualmente sentarmos no chão da
escola como todos os que fazem parte da
comunidade como os pais com os
professores com é toda a equipa
educativa com as famílias associações de
poder local
isso tudo com as crianças e jovens
porque só no fundo para quem estamos a
fazer esse trabalho e é a partir dessa
base que nós vamos pensar a escola que
temos na escola que nós queremos e com
problemas e reconstruir e foi nessa
altura que portanto desde este encontro
surge um grupo de pessoas que quer
sonhar juntos e estes sonhos são
coletivos e e surgem e insurgem
motivados por um repensar da educaçã
surgem porque queremos encontrar novas
formas de evitar e queremos pensar
também em questões ambientais questões
desenvolvimento pessoal e
desenvolvimento comunitário
então criamos uma kombi na aprendizagem
de aprendizagem é apresentada projeta
chegou como uma escola um espaço de
convivência onde as pessoas anos jovens
crianças e os adultos partilham têm
acesso à informação desenvolvem
competências em matemática e das
ciências das línguas e transforma esse
conhecimento e essa informação
e esse conhecimento é partilhado e
portanto é uma voz muito
beto é um projeto com base numa
sociedade sustentável e então é e sujo
como stranger ina uma comunidade de
aprendizagem neste momento começamos é
portanto faz agora um ano em que de
emissão deste projecto e apresentamos a
nossa proposta a câmera você dá nos um
espaço em uma escola desativada em
santiago candoso esta comunidade de
aprendizagem
junto com juntou os sonhos de todos o
espírito de equipa com base nos sonhos
da equipa de sonho no fundo a integração
do sonho de cada um no projeto
inspirador que promova o desenvolvimento
sustentável
baseando-se na elétrica para uma cultura
que é cuidar das pessoas cuidar da terra
e partilhar os incidentes e esta é como
juntos e éticas a conduzir nos a nossa
missão que é cultivar o desenvolvimento
integral humanos e em sonhos e colhendo
nova realidade e esta missão com estes
sonhos que nós estamos a requalificar o
espaço tornando ecoeficiente
desenvolvemos princípios
autossustentável
além de cid o objetivo é que esse espaço
albergue os sonhos de cada um
neste momento já temos em
desenvolvimento é uma escola de educação
ambiental um espaço com o working
comunitário oficinas espaço oficinas uma
cantina associativa
hum várias vários vários encontros
futuros palestras cursos na área da
sustentabilidade da tecnologia na
educação das artes
promovemos a comunicação autêntica o
mais fofo mas o yoga e todas um conjunto
de atividades que promovem tema nossas
em movimento envolve crianças famílias e
adultos num mesmo conceito de comunidade
de aprendizagem
nós temos muito vincado esta necessidade
e contribuímos para a mudança da
educação para a mudança da escola
pública e para a mudança de visão uma
educação integral e ao longo da vida
por isso nós temos um centro educativo
onde cada criança e jovem adulto pode
desenvolver as suas aprendizagens de uma
forma em geral e para isso nós fazemos
parte de uma rede viva promove e liga
soas de projetos desta natureza que
pretendem que a educação seja fã e ativa
e que promova o que cada um de nós tem
de mais mais interessantes que seja ao
encontro da nossa natureza e que proteja
o nosso e desenvolva proteger também e
desenvolver nosso talento pessoal
estes princípios da educação em vez de
caçá desta rede promover esta educação
mas também contamos com a ajuda de uma
orientação de uma escola internacional
escola tomara que promove uma tutoria é
uma escola de apoio à aprendizagem
individual e que no fundo hoje orienta
todos os os pais nem todos os projetos e
com esse tutor da escola é um currículo
próprio para cada criança
aquela jovem cada um tem o seu projeto
pedagógico baseando se na sua
necessidade no seu objetivo
eu tenho três filhos e que não tem o seu
vai ter o seu método e isso é isso e o
seu caminho para ocorrer diferenciado e
autêntico
é com este porte que nós desenvolvemos
atividades e que que trabalhamos em
equipa para também ser um projeto aberto
a todos
damos as mãos e sonhamos juntos
entregamos todos os sonhos e todos os
dias está a acontecer nós então é
introduzimos uma ferramenta que o dragão
do enem que é uma ferramenta que
possibilita que está também um movimento
de transição e mentor de projectos
sustentáveis e que possibilita criar
através de algumas etapas simples um
espírito realmente de ligação uns com os
outros e viver nesse respeito com a
natureza e com a natureza própria que
não eu nós tínhamos nós planejamos
fazemos isso lembramos estão contínuo ou
seja nós tentamos sempre introduzir
novos sonhos todos os dias surgem novos
sonhos novas pessoas
as mesmas pessoas com novos sonhos e ea
sempre teve espaço para todos
em colaboração numa com uma participação
responsável é voluntária
não existe ninguém que tem a
responsabilidade mas sim mas vamos lá
que é partilhada uma compressão wilson
ea solidariedade são valores que
assentam no nosso projeto
todas as atividades que nós
desenvolvemos vão encontrar exatamente
dessa espírito que nós acreditamos que é
possível um sonho flor está construir a
sua casa e brincar
eu tô nem aí o que achou da nato está
aprendendo a cuidar de eu amo eu espero
que o que acredito que os sonhos são
possíveis realizar
acredito numa sociedade mais
participativa de termos uma educação que
previu hoje as competências para o
século 21
e nesta mudança da escola da escola e da
aprendizagem e vai assinar conosco nós
estamos abertos a receber todos os
sonhos e troféus realidade trata de água
[Aplausos]